hey everyone this is Steve W trob I'm
here at the cinema center at marble uh
in Toronto uh this is our studio for
this year's Tiff and I am here with
writer director mother couch writer
director Nicholas lson nice to be here
how are you doing sir I'm good I'm good
it's kind of early though it is but uh
and thank you for uh uh stopping in
early your our first interview up on
Saturday morning cool um so I I really
want to get into the most important
question front uh am I going to get an
episode uh of uh the the diner or of
magic Diner part chis you know what yes
sure I'll I I'll I'll write one for you
right okay uh it's important though so
for people that don't realize you did
two shorts uh for Vogue and you had Anna
in both and like you had a big movie
star talk a little bit about those real
quick for people who haven't seen them
because they are on Vimeo and they're
good and they're short so you can watch
them with ease they go quick
um dude it's a great story actually so
they did they did approach a bunch of
really cool directors for making those
shorts right because it was a great
opportunity for directors to work with
actors for their magazine covers or
whatever I think Vogue has this like one
actor one model and then like they have
12 issues a year so it's like six shorts
with actors and me and Alysia we were
great friends and all of a sudden I get
she was doing her Oscar push for the
Danish girl and vog calls me they're
like would you want to write something
we have a secret we have a but we we
can't tell you who's on the cover yet
and I'm like oh sure I'll write
something and then I have breakfast with
Alysia she's like I'm GNA be on the
cover of Vogue I'm like I think I'm
writing a short for you for rogue so uh
so that was just a weird coincidence and
I did write it and it's based on it's
based on this Twilight Zone episode nick
of time so we found this little like a
napkin holder and I just started riffing
we had like you know maybe 3 hours to do
it it was supposed to be Matt Damon
coming in in the
diner yeah this is true it was supposed
to be Matt Damon he wanted to do it but
he was in he was in Las Vegas shooting I
think the born film so he was like
unfortunately I'm stuck in Vegas like
this was the day before I'm like great
who do we have around who can be the one
coming in and breaking the the sort of
wall
and the vog people were like well Anna
is at a hotel close by and she's maybe
she can stop by on the way to the
airport so she did and uh working with
Anna was great and then for the second
one I'm like well I got to keep I got to
but then for the second one she was like
so into it she came up she came like two
hours before she wanted to like talk
about her character she's like is it
okay if I stand like this how should I
what do I I'm like you know are you just
picking up your eggs you know that's the
the uh but yeah it's great yeah so
that's how it started yeah um for people
that haven't seen them uh something
about those is you like magic realism
which is something that's like a part of
your work so what is it about the magic
realism and that sort of thing that
keeps pulling you in I think
it's based on the movies I grew up with
I'm born in
1990 so 13 going 30 I was like 12 13
years no but this is true sure I know
and like Freaky Friday and like Princess
Diaries like I grew up with those like
it sounds maybe benal but I love those
movies I was blown away by I I think I
watched Freaky Friday like 200 times
when I was like
13 and uh in love with Lin Lohan you
know and I think the the the scope of
magic
realism uh it's such a beautiful way to
explain either metaphors or EXP explore
worlds so a a development of that is
that you go into bonell and you go into
the the deeper the deeper sense of a of
a sort of a a director sort of a
writer's uh Journey so you know I just
love those films like the swimmer an
incredible movie like um They Shoot
Horses Don't They also like on a on a
different scale of magical realism but
it's still there right so it's something
with with the what a camera ra can do uh
that I just I'm obsessed with well the
other thing is that like that's one of
the reasons people love movies is to
escape from reality and imagine what
would happen if if this could happen to
me this is it you know what I mean and
um you know and obviously the genres of
like uh the apocalyptic future is the
same it's it's magic realism but in a
completely different way you know
imagining what you anyway it's a I like
the movies me too and I
think it is Magic like movies are
magical you know so why not bend the
rules a little and why not explore other
worlds and cuz you're allowed to I mean
you
know Interstellar it's magical realism
we haven't done that obviously you know
he had noan had a little more money did
he he did but only only $500 I'm not
sure he did we had the same we were on
the same budget level obviously yeah
yeah all right so jumping into why you
get to be here uh so everyone watching
this will not have seen your movie maybe
two people will have you and me right
exactly so for people that don't for
people that don't know much about the
film how have you been telling friends
and family like what it's
about I know here it here it comes the
the oneliner have you practiced it's no
I haven't dude I'm so bad at this it's
about Ellen Burston on a
couch but that is actually very true
however there's a little more to it and
I don't know how much more you want to
say it's about everything literally I
think you know what I wanted to make a
movie that was similar to the Greek
masks you know the theater mask like it
was a happy face and a sad face and you
know they flip really quickly to go with
the that's the villain and that's the
and I think that's very intrigu that's
beautiful that's Cinema and that's what
it should be should be it should be
happy face and sad face so so yeah it's
Ellen bur on a couch and a happy happy
face and a sad face one of the things
about the film and I think you would
agree is after you've seen it all the
way through and you watch it a second
time will have a different you'll have a
different perspective on things would
you agree I uh yeah I'm I'm a huge
rewatchable kind of guy I love watching
my favorite films twice I think movies
that's the beauty about movies it
they're usually not more than two hours
and you can like you can you you can
find stuff in movies uh on a second
watch that you you didn't and I made it
for a second watch and Third Watch I
made it for the Reddit Community to like
sort of you know right I mean you've
seen it so and it's so much hidden and
it's so many sort of Alleyways of
metaphors so um I want here's the thing
so I read that what happened was you
gave the crew very detailed information
about each scene but gave the actors
none of this that's true so when did so
talk a little bit about why you wanted
to do this and part two of that is when
did the actors actually find out when
did you inform them of without going
into spoilers mo more information about
the movie and and what may or may not be
happening I realized during prep that my
crew kept coming with these questions of
like where are we what's going on and
I'm like I was so sick and tired of them
not understanding me fully in my script
uh which is sparse it's just dialogue so
I decided in prep to write this very
detailed book I call a storm book and
it's sort of nine chapters guiding my
team on a very literal level where we
are what's going on and where we're
going
um the core of each scene and how many
Furniture um uh appears and and and
stuff so I gave my crew this book and we
actually developed the whole schedule
was based on this book so we could go we
didn't shoot in in in in order so we
could go from Storm 2 which was the
beginning of the film and people like
all right I'm prepping storm 6 over here
do you want to go check it so it was a
very easy way to communicate with my
crew of where we were in the movie cuz
it I mean you know it's like it's one
location but it's also so many locations
right and I realiz I I I I debated with
myself I'm like should I give this to
the actors or shouldn't so I so I asked
you and McGregor and I asked Ellen I'm
like do you want to read it
and I think unanimously we said I think
it's better not to and just stick to
what's said on the actual paper and what
we're going to shoot and by doing that
it was a beautiful way of them not
knowing but the crew knew exactly where
we're going and what's what was going on
and we had we had conversations me and
you and and Ellen and Taylor we're like
all right should we know here exactly
where we're going I'm like no explore it
let's go let's go let's go explore this
scene let's let's see where this takes
us and sometimes because I I wrote The
Storm book before shooting sometimes I
had to change the storm book I'm like
all right they actually discovered
something in the scene that I didn't I
didn't see coming so it was a beautiful
it was a kind of a translation between
the actors in front of the camera and uh
and um and the crew you know here's the
thing though there are some directors
like you know like let's talk about a
kubric and I'm not putting you in the
kubric thing obviously because that you
got be well you have to have a much
longer resume um but what I'm saying is
there's a lot of directors I.E kubric
that do not want to explain things and
there are other directors who really do
like to break down things at all were
you nervous at all about giving out a
book to people that literally explains
what this movie is and what's going on
because you are removing the ability if
that ever comes out for people to sort
of interpret it for themselves well
first of all I'm not going to go public
with this book so that my audience will
never read this book I think that's a
that's that was a distinction I made
because it's not for the audience but
for my crew for my creative team I think
it's a necessity uh Clarity is a
necessity I myself I've been uh I've
been a crew member and been an actor and
and having a director who hides um stuff
from the crew I find uh quite
frustrating uh and I think it's actually
hiding your insecurities more so than
hiding what you so so I'm like I know
exactly where I want to go why not just
tell my team where I want to go and we
can together go there because you know
it's a comple it's a very complex film
and uh and uh I needed I needed them to
be on on par with me uh in order to
spitball ideas of how walls should break
and how where we we going you know so
this is probably the most important next
most important question from the
beginning um as someone who uh lives in
I believe Sweden yeah I live in New York
but I'm Swedish right exactly so how do
you feel about Ikea love Ikea
are you kidding man it's funny because
it's when I was a kid it was a game we
in it was a Swedish game you uh you hid
in like cabinets and closets and
underneath rugs or whatever to closing
hours and they have night guards but
they usually just have one night guard
who makes rounds so you stayed after
hours with friends and you just live
there and you just hid because it's so
big right sure I yeah yeah and it was
it's a surreal experience because you
it's a theater because it sets it stages
I mean everyone who who's been at AIA
would know that it's like a kitchen and
then you walk into a living room and
then so you get the live you get the
life experience have you ever thought of
someone from there because personally I
I mean it's Ikea is a movie waiting to
happen I just don't know what the movie
is do you know what I mean yeah I really
I mean yeah he's quite a controversial
figure the guy started so either it's a
really dark biopic or a funny blue and
blue and yellow I don't know what that
would be but I think maybe this is a
little bit of a Ikea to be honest there
is a little bit of an Ikea es to this
good I like it so one of the things
about the film is that you have to
decide where and when you want to reveal
information to the audience so in the
editing room did you make any changes
and how did it sort of work because you
do have to eventually give things yeah
that was a that was a it was a ride man
it was a it was one of those things um
it was a puzle to make sure not giving
too much but not um um uh withholding
too much cuz that's just frustrating to
watch it was a point in the edit let's
say four months in where it didn't make
any sense the film and were you ready to
jump out of a window yeah yeah no kill
myself P like yeah but uh but I didn't
thank God and uh you find your way in
and then you start
introducing uh uh moments of clarity and
then you reach a point when it's too
clear everything is too clear and you're
like all right we're not going here so
now you have two and then you find this
little weird middle ground and um I
remember starting testing the film it
was it was a beautiful it was a
beautiful uh narrative going from people
saying I didn't get this at all to
people actually getting the themes and
the story I'm like all right cool here
we go this is it this is a good you know
place to be so talk this is your first
feature and I'm curious you put together
a great cast um did you have like
blackmail pictures on you in and
everybody else or how did you manage to
pull everyone into the movie yeah hired
a bunch of Paparazzi and I I uh yeah
nude shots of Ellen you know through the
window of her yeah yeah yeah and I just
said look do you want this or do you
want to make my movie I'm a I'm a I'm a
letter writer I wrote letters to them I
uh no it's a Dreamcast man like it's
it's one of those things that I I'm so
lucky to I'm so lucky to I'm so bad with
mic yeah I'm like as he as he's going
like this yeah to I'm a floater um I'm
so lucky to um I mean these are the best
actors in the world like I I think when
you write something genuinely um from
the heart I think actors have an ability
an incredible ability to sense truth on
a script in a
script I think that's what they read and
that's why I was able to get this this
cast um because I was truly writing from
the heart and and those Act you see in
the movie they were my first choices
really so
um it was as easy as just handing over
the script having a cup of tea with
Ellen Burston and she said she wanted to
do it was she the first one she was the
first no Yan was the first one and then
we went to Ellen talk a little bit about
premiering your movie at Tiff I know
it's like a little bit of a generic
thing but like this is I love this Film
Festival so what does it mean to you to
actually be here it's one of those
things like you sort of invited into the
special Club it's uh
it's I couldn't imagine any place better
to Premiere my film tonally and and the
audience is it it's just one of those
festivals that are famous for
being it's for the audience like this is
it's a it's an abundance of it's a candy
store and it's it's so inclusive that I
think most Festival especially European
festivals they can they can be sort of
exclusive this is not it and my film if
anything I hope is an inclusive
exclusive Journey you know so I'm I'm
curious um are you one of these people
that has a bunch of scripts in your desk
or a bunch of ideas that you're now
trying to pursue or are you know what I
mean like what are you thinking about
for the future I think I have my next
two films in my head yeah for sure I
have one half written um but yeah hell
yeah I have tons of ideas so many weird
ideas do do they have magic realism hell
yeah
yeah do they involve Ikea yeah totally
it's that one of one of the films is an
Ikea yeah thing yeah for sure no but I
mean it's like what this is um a lot of
people who are making their first
feature it's like you and you must know
this by just looking at Hollywood
history like your first feature can be a
make or break of your career because it
you know if it doesn't work you might
not be getting another chance so how
much did you debate I mean h yeah I know
you're right you're right much
frightening yeah how much did you debate
is this the movie I want to do as my
first feature not much at all it's one
of those things as an artist I think I
hope every artist has this like you you
just have to do it and it's like it
comes from such a deep deep within that
you can't think of like strategically
like I have those people thinking
strategically you know like my managers
and like and and even even if they say I
don't think this is a good because
people did say that people said maybe
it's too pushy maybe it's too weird
maybe it's but if it's something I as an
artist I need to paint this picture then
I just have to paint it right so I try
not to think about that at all I don't
want to be a a strategist at Wall Street
I'm not that kind of I this is from the
heart this is a messy I think beautiful
emotional ride that I think a lot of
people can relate to I can and if I can
I hope that you know a big audience can
as well you know yeah my my thing and
and the thing I enjoyed about your movie
is I wasn't exactly sure where it was
going and um and I think you've seen a
lot of movies we've all seen a lot of
movies and anytime I'm watching a movie
like there's I can predict so much when
I'm watching a film because there's only
when a movie's two hours there's only so
many places it can go so anytime I don't
know where it's going to go I'm like
great yeah because it keeps me invested
you're right and those are the movies I
love I like truly love those movies
because and you're you have this
incredible you uh you steal two hours
from somebody right and you better make
you better make those two hours wor
worthwhile H and I F I feel sometimes
when I can predict a movie I sit there
I've invested this time and I I know
exactly where the movie is going and the
movie is going exactly where I thought
it was going I'm like yo I could have
what like I could have just dreamt this
up and stayed home you know so if
anything I wanted to go from here to
Beyond and I don't think anyone could
can predict ending I would agree with
you um and I've seen a few movies at
Tiff this year that I was like oh wow
they're really doing that like but
anyway listen I'm just going to say
congrats on being part of Tiff and for
coming in our studio and a huge thank
you to everyone at the cinema center and
for making this happen and seriously
have a fantastic thanks so much man
thank you I appreciate
it